small round and hearty meatballs are a
national dish in Sweden nearly every
restaurant there serves them Casey
Bavarian a chef at the go pool and
restaurant in Stockholm makes them to
everyone knows meatballs but the Swedish
mean suppose has to be small spicy with
the old spice rich not dry and it always
comes with the lingonberry and cucumber
as a combination the concept at GU
Berlin is traditional Swedish fair the
restaurant is on the grounds of the
sconce an open-air Museum which shows
how people lived in Sweden a hundred
years ago back then the meat grinder had
just been invented making it a lot
easier to prepare the ground meat for
the meatballs their success can be
traced to the restaurant in Stockholm
Opera House the head chef Tory rettman
served them at his buffet in 1963 one
former employee remembers how the
meatballs or shut bill are found
international acclaim in 1964 triphala
both first expedited in the world is
efficient in New York and then this
young Japan will have this restaurant
started a company with the name of
Sweden smuggle food and was traveling
around the rest of the world and have
always the main piece of the Snuggle
food water supplies film set in Sweden
and books about the country also
referred to the meatballs they are
Astrid Lindgren Carlson on the roast
favorite food and in the first season of
The Muppet Show Oh cook called the
swedish chef made them but it was a
swedish furniture giant that made the
meatballs a household name the world
over each of its stores has a restaurant
and since 1985 they've all served
meatballs last year alone ikea sold more
than a billion of them
it's the same receive all over there
ikea markets and yeah it's a Swedish
tradition and we can we can have it out
all over the world and it's easy to like
even for children and for others since
2015 ikea has also offered vegetarian
and poultry varieties I have a brother
who live in bangkok it works that and he
always goes wiki and it's simple it's
like a tradition when you go to eat here
you take the minerals that good and she
if you do it at your home of course it's
better meatballs shaped by hand kc ball
barrier swears by them it takes only 20
minutes to make them there a simple dish
with scope for variation i guess there's
as many received of meat was that there
is grandmas in sweden this is
traditional spices with allspice and
black pepper and then my personal
favorite is to add a little fennel seeds
if you turn the meatballs every 20
seconds in the frying pan they stay
juicy the Swedes have very clear ideas
about what side dishes go with them it's
a lingonberries because it has a sweet
and sour flavors cucumbers because it's
a freshness and the potato become quite
cream and that's why you need the sites
nowadays there are even restaurants that
offer only should belong two years ago a
restaurant named meatballs for the
people opened in Stockholm every day it
serves 14 different kinds for example
with reindeer meat truffles or chili the
restaurant keeps experimenting we've
actually done about a hundred different
kinds of meatballs and we did beer
meatball and which was we got both a
good and a bad reaction from it that it
was really strong and flavor it's quite
man meaty whether they're novel or
classic Swedish meatballs are here to
stay